tony is with us in Atlanta Georgia hi
Tony welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
better than I deserve what's up I have
been divorced for like two and a half
years my ex-husband and I still have a
credit card debts to pay thats in my
name it is a month of work paperwork
that he has to pay it but I don't know
what to do if I have the money to pay
off the bill and like should I sit and
hold on to it or should I make him
continue to pay me like pay it side by
side I don't know what to do once I have
the money to pay the whole entire zola
how much is owed on it right now it's
about eighty seven hundred dollars
what does he make it here um I don't
know he likes to be in and out of jobs
all the time
so do you think he's going to pay this
bill I think will continue to pay it is
its own and and the court ruling was
that he can take 20 years to pay it off
there was no time limit we had
originally agreed my urmass at the time
it was eaten off in October of this year
once he lost the job gotten and had to
take a break like I know they'll always
be a crisis coming for him yeah and what
did you make last year about sixty eight
thousand and I'll probably make maybe 78
thousand this year have you got any
other debt no this is the last one how
many kids have you got
okay well the way I answer questions is
what would I do if I woke up in your
shoes okay the benefit of waiting on him
to maybe someday be responsible which is
something he's never done in his life to
date which would surprise all of us at
this point if that were to actually
happened the only benefit to you is four
thousand three hundred and fifty dollars
am i right correct I wouldn't screw with
it for a foreground I just pay it off
what should I do
asked her I would call the I would ask
your attorney if you can set it up as a
note for him to pay you and then when he
doesn't pay you I wouldn't be shocked
okay I would just move on sitting around
waiting on someone to do something that
you know they're not going to do is a
long bunch of drama mm-hmm and I
wouldn't be able that for four grand if
I were you you know whatever you want to
do but I just I would in other words I
would try to get him to pay it I would
try to hold him to his feet to the fire
but you've given me a real low opinion
of him and you have in terms of his
ability to stay responsible and follow
through on obligations and so if he does
you and I are both going to be surprised
okay but I can't run this for another I
mean you're gonna be tied to this goober
for another three years screwing around
for $4,000 you know mm-hmm I'd get it
out of my life now before you do let's
try to get him to tie you know call your
attorney and ask your attorney if you
can get them to sign a note for it
because you're just gonna pay it off
it's in your name anyway if he doesn't
pay it you got to pay it so you might as
well just be done with it done with him
and then if he happens to send you a
check we'll all just act shocked and so
let's go with that
hey thanks for the call